we've got 15 people holding so we can
keep going let's go next to our collar
we may be going to a local file we've
got a caller from the six one seven area
code caller tell us your name tell us
where you're calling from and what's on
your mind today
hi yeah I saw your program yesterday on
Democracy Now well we're not on
democracy at the democracy now do a
story where they used a clip of our show
is that what you mean yeah yeah yeah we
has a Democrat Party being broken up
okay and and democra and that piece said
again you that was on a never been zero
then yeah it was that Lisa tour was at
an old one well no I think we might be
talking about two different things so we
do we do the David Pakman show which is
not part of democracy now did we did a
story about the Democratic Party
devouring itself did was that you saw
that on Democracy Now where you saw it
on the same station yeah yeah I saw it
on Democracy Now that's why I shot our
free speech TV which can we oh it won't
be Steve we're the show right after the
mock I now on free speech got it
okay go ahead sir yes I am I on the show
right now oh we're on the air right now
yeah this is the show okay
yeah I was kind of fascinated by you're
trying to bring the party back together
considering that there are those who
won't accept brainwashing and those who
will and I think that's the basic
problem I've never voted Republican in
my life okay and I've found out that
when these four different entities all
told me not to vote for Trump you know
who I'm talking about know what four
entities told you not to vote Trump the
Chinese Communist okay
the Saudis who throw gay people off
buildings the Chinese Communists who
killed Buddhists and sell their body
parts and also the New World Order Pope
you've got all kinds of good of file
problems right now okay
and vicente fox who wants a North
American Union well they all told me I
ought to book the Trump yeah my number
one question to them was what the bleep
information is what right do you have to
tell me who to vote for and number two I
thank them for telling me that because
now I knew who the real candidate was I
had no choice in this election wait a
second let's see what if I may if I may
let me just ask a few just simple short
question so we can figure out what's
going on here who when you say the real
candidate that you figured out who was
the real candidate well when you have a
choice you're choosing between two
relatively similar items correct not all
choices are between similar items no but
most choices when you're in voting when
you choice
your choices are generally between
similar items correct I don't agree with
that now okay well anyway that's the way
I see it all right because you know who
would put up a not qualified person and
so when I had to choose between a
successful lying criminal who sold you
know uranium to the Russians okay for 30
million dollars and a successful
businessperson I didn't have a choice
and what choice did you make I voted for
the only person who solution
illegitimate of the two I would have
rather had three choices which was
interesting I don't know who this guy
voted for can you tell I maybe they're
embarrassed to tell you did you vote for
Trump or Hillary sir I voted for traffic
as a I had no choice
I couldn't do anything else so could you
have voted for Hillary Clinton if that
was the best we could get yes but there
wasn't so you just said you could have
voted for Hillary Clinton but that you
had no choice but to vote for Trump how
does that square
you don't quite understand do you
I think you're right I think the problem
has I'm not understanding yeah yeah
when when somebody can steal 96% of the
money they can supposedly get the
Haitians where'd you get that where'd
you come up with that now talk to me
about that where where'd you learn that
Hillary rule 96 I don't have to look it
up you'll find it you will know but
you've you know you've asserted it
you've asserted it you can't cite the
source you asserted that the Bush's see
you know you're part of the
establishment you can't even admit that
the Clintons and the bushes are part of
the same crime prep on a second Oh sir
can we if you will if you'll indulge me
you asserted that Hillary Clinton took
96% of the money from Haitians I didn't
so can you cite a source for that I
think you can look it up and you can
find it you'll find but I'm not the one
making ideas findable thank God for the
Internet
you know Trump would never been elected
if it wasn't an Internet thanks God is
that who you say would pardon so you're
thanking God that there was an Internet
yes oh and I'm not even a religious
person but I become religious after the
internet here and internet made you
actually that's fascinating because the
internet usually makes people I think on
balance would make people less religious
but this is someone who's been made
religious by the Internet that's
interesting and also isn't religious but
also isn't because I I have to be able
to get the full story and now the full
story is out and enough people got the
full story that they figured it out I
mean you do know that the Democrat Party
was the one selected by the KKK no I
didn't know that what do you mean by
that you should check it up look up KKK
and Democrat Party you'll find it you'll
find it I mean I've never voted
Republican until this time if Trump was
the guy that I don't do a real quick sir
I've got a runner one thing you said
makes me and where we're at on this day
that you finally get the full truth on
the Internet what websites would you say
on the internet give you the full truth
um sometimes right Clark sometimes
Infowars
sometimes you know there's a bunch of
them I'll see ya all right well we had
I'm ready for the check we are ready for
the bill and then we'll just wrap up and
get going sir thank you I appreciate it
very very interesting and six one seven
number in Boston accent so that's at
least we can we can rest easy knowing
that he had no impact on the election
results that's the only opportunity
votes here in Massachusetts all right
let's take a break and then we'll
continue with your calls in just a
minute